watching icfc um black kazama when he
played against cadillac
he kind of put a highlight reel on he
kind of embarrassed him a little bit man
so i know khalid wants to run back
because blacazar kind of embarrassed him
the last time they played but here we go
vermillion gate sister lily this time uh
sam not the uh not the lydia yeah
interesting maybe he just had that that
sort of lydia against uh or he just knew
the match up a little bit better with
the lydia and because right now we're
seeing them back on uh the kalak
mainstay the lily just really i want you
guys to watch out for neutral hop kicks
and sidestep matterhorns that is the
scariest thing to see kalec is able to
use those tools so effectively which in
normal situations you're not really
supposed to use them but uh let's see
straight away black kazama they come out
of the gates swinging maybe kalec
doesn't want this passive style that i
was talking about earlier on big walls
flat here yeah i think that was quite
brave to go for uh the ford ford four
low against black casama to start off i
mean she has asked her has so many tools
to be able to beat stuff like that but
hey cadillac has a good little um
intention there from character another
he wants to go in there and just put his
put the pressure on yeah okay it doesn't
finish the string there nice job big low
parry though
both of these players really want this
momentum
oh wow
it connects technically airborne so it
doesn't do a lot of damage and black
design takes it with it down fight yeah
that was that was interesting upward
through the start of the round again
black ozama
again like trying to get this run back
from the last time they played and what
a stage to do on as well on the loser
bracket of top eight here for the
marshall event
yeah losers quarter final now this is uh
this is where your money starts uh
multiplying and your points start
multiplying the further into the bracket
you get callak really wants this has
been placing consistently well in the
icf seas has a lot of points to his name
but wants even more big whiffs there no
punish really
palik looking for something big here
he's slowing the pace of the game right
down
it's the
full conversion here
oh wow okay
yeah no chicken there and blackstone's
gonna love that cause he is someone who
loves to use the parries yeah
definitely did it
nearly going for the unblockable here
watch the rage six seconds left on the
clock
oh no
i don't know is that the player right
there maybe bait him in with a low first
before you throw the rage right out but
blacazama up two rounds against calact
right now
yeah it starts again though starts to
round with the counter hit black because
someone just seems to have calyx number
man honestly but it comes down to the
character known to be a guy with weird
timing but there is nothing there's
there's no weirder time than black
kazamas for sure
definitely and we haven't seen any of
the tools that i was talking about to
start that neutral hopkick or the
sidestep matterhorn which usually kalec
just throws out there and they always
seem to work yeah but uh last chance for
colic here now in game one
[Music]
uh punished over here yeah wow okay
finish the string that was a
uh a bit of a high risk um
low reward there for kalak which is uh
not usual not even at all he definitely
panicked you know you saw the rage yard
there in the second round and then right
the end they're using that back 10
string just not something that you
usually see khalak do
um and like you said sam it wasn't going
to be a big reward either way right a
very very risky thing to throw out i
think we're definitely going to get a
character switch it's probably going to
be the lydia because it's gotten this
far the kuni mitsu could come out it's
just it's definitely the lily is gone
now that's it we're not gonna get that
low match up anymore
yeah i don't it's uh it just didn't look
great i mean i don't know was it the
character matchup but sometimes
especially at this level of the
tournament sometimes the character
switch can just kind of reset your
mental like you know if you're coming
off that loss and you're kind of half
tilted and stuff just switch out the
character you know if you can play them
which kind of can at this super super
high level of tech and has pulled them
out in tournaments before and as you
said gotten this fire with the lydia
maybe that's the shout
yeah i think the lydia is going to be
the character that's been coming out
here versus black ozama i need to do
something man i think that it's not even
the matchup we're not even talking about
matchups it's just about being
comfortable when you play against black
kazama some people really turn up way
too much because they know that he's the
kind of guy who'd like to throw out
those panic moves he'll be very
unpredictable with his offense um and of
course asica has so many defensive tools
the the reversals the sabacces and the
the evasion the all these things right
so people always turn a lot versus black
summer too much i know caleb didn't want
to do that but he needs to have a
different approach he needs to have a
different approach to black zombie for
sure let's see what counts he's going to
go for here's 1-0 right now to black
because i'm a three-round straight was
that last match no round brown what is
it going to be and it's the lydia yeah
absolutely yeah um yeah as i said just
reset the mental see what uh see what he
can do here at the losers quarter final
here for the tekken online challenge of
eu west
yep so let's see man we're going to go
to the arena so the walls are in play
here
can cadillac stay alive here in this
master event and continue on in this top
eight there's a loser bracket action
ladies and gents france versus spain
black kazama looking super super solid
yeah you see black azam are always
trying to start their own with a big
country
wow you see that is the the sweep cancel
enter into the into the parry i mean
this guy has so many crazy setups man
nobody plays astra like him
nobody plays tekken like this
man
he's got this khalik
once again slowing the pace of the game
down and really just wants to play it at
his pace good punish there
pushing forward pushing a little bit
more buttons though than he was with the
uh
with the um
lily
extending it forward here mostly center
stage
elbow drop
on his head
what a block okay
he knows this
the damage sam throws crazy that's a lot
of damage for you
six seconds left colic
finish it off with the string okay a
little bit of uh light now
um in the french camp here
oh
back dash down forward two we like that
one
going to the wall here here we go flip
over as well max damage with a delay
nice hopkins but the combo will be cut
short because of the wall
nice there's a savage
gets the full pick up here oh no
that was weird pushing buttons there now
he got caught ducking them and he
thought the low was coming black hasn't
even been going for many lows here but
let's see what he can do now are they
going to start coming out
i think
he's kind of running out of uh tricks
left in the bag here he's probably gonna
have to start bringing some laws out but
there we go black azama is ready
nice block there doesn't get a great
punish though launched
pushing forward remember guys is almost
out of the tournament here if black azam
can take the next two rounds that's him
out of the tournament yeah
and he's pushing him closer to the wall
right now it's a very even round at the
moment
yeah
punish i didn't commit though
just sending it forward a little bit
oh
punish that yeah
oh went for the grab there really weird
okay very very slow-paced game but it's
only about 13 seconds left on the clock
nice
oh
huge damage as you keep saying swag big
big damage on that great round under
there especially if you're not using it
yeah and we haven't seen any chickens
right as well from these reversals black
is over with a lovely low power here we
go we're gonna go to the final round
looking for the unblockable but puts him
puts his own back to the wall there lost
all wall pressure here
alec is just chasing him down here get
inside don't you get up like that sir
big damage here even on the live lead
again 33 seconds left on the clock keep
an eye on it all ladies and gentlemen
that will come into play here
patience
oh my god the wool splat this might be
dead reward back with a back dash and
ladies and gents black designer now on
set point to eliminate cadillac from the
top eight
diamond i you can't call it but what a
block already black ozama lifts him up
here and this should be the wall this is
where he wants to be unblockable he gets
up too late oh no
oh man damage this is not where you want
to be if your character right now good
punish down the string go for the low
guaranteed hit on the ground cannot now
working on the comeback
oh oh
the patience the hell sweeps
back three
no punishing oh
about even
oh no the reversal
how do you look
oh my god cadillac
gets away with murder beautiful
beautiful come back there but you have
to say black ozama he choked that one
sam he choked it hard he choked if
somebody give that man a heimlich
maneuver he's joking
that was insane that was his game right
there he had the parry into the wall
splat all he needed to do and then all
we saw was a neutral four he wanted no
he wanted to go for the one plus four he
didn't bind the buttons correctly he
accidentally hit the four instead of one
plus four and that was that was gigi's
right there man caller got up and he's a
very clutch player as well khalik in
those scramble situations you do not
want to give this man an opportunity to
make a comeback because he will do it
and ladies and gentlemen now going to a
final match and when you win matches
which you shouldn't have won it gives
you a lot of momentum going into the
final match i believe black ozama will
be going to an infinite stage now but i
really feel like now calyx and i have a
lot of momentum and confidence going
into this final match yeah definitely i
mean black ozama that was his match that
was his round that was that was it that
was him moving forward in the tournament
and just a couple of mistakes there and
i mean
now we're in final game territory this
is everything is on the line the loser
goes home right now like
there's no extra chances there's no more
lives
oh this is uh this is getting worried
worryful or worrisome if you're uh one
of our spanish supporters here in the
chat
um your boy is on his last legs right
now
yeah i mean you got to be uh if you're
black zombie you've got to get that out
of your head you know you had the win
the reversals are working right
reversals are working the uh the timing
is on point we've seen a lot of counter
hits throughout this set from black
kazama if you're like a zombie right now
you should be uh trying your best to get
that last match out of your head i know
it should have been the win but
if you if it stays in there then kallak
will meant to come back this guy knows
how to switch it up as well caleb is not
a one-dimensional player he's he's able
to play really random and aggressive and
he's able to play very defensive as well
so we're going to the infinite just like
i thought you know black ozama doesn't
like to really have the walls in play um
now let's see what we can do yeah i mean
one of these guys is going home ladies
and gentlemen let's get a bit pumped
right now
okay
starting off black azam it does not look
shook though i mean which is good to
know
yeah i am interested to see how these
guys are going to approach this first
round looks like blacks aren't playing
quite defensively right now in cadillac
i'm just going in
yeah
oh
okay just uh gets that cartwheel kick
out of it no more nonsense here
i like leading on life here remember
guys these have gone down to the wire
before oh just a little bit short on the
tooth fairy
run up harry
oh boy oh oh
okay good blocks good defense here
punish
nice
oh man
i think doug from paris might have
taught calico to block those that's the
first time i feel like he's not even
gone for that load this whole set and it
was blocked but nice counting that's a
chunk of damage damn look at the damage
already man it's going to be big 50
oh okay
he knew it was a one trick one trick
hell's
coming out
looking for it again
i doubt the pokes in this match are
definitely adding up right now for both
players folks are playing a huge part
but 30 seconds left on the talk ladies
and gentlemen
[Music]
okay nice
now that should be dead if he gets lost
it doesn't what a block oh nothing to
encounter it
yeah i mean i had a feeling that was
what he was gonna do while standing four
after when after asking hits while 74
down two is a frame trap if you press
any buttons you will get count hit you
can't even sidestep it because the watts
94 is so plus the double reversal
attempt there i like it i like it this
guy's crazy
yep
colic not falling for any of the tricks
though
okay
just back dashing away collec is playing
super defensively right now
yeah definitely keep an eye on the clock
guys because
um with kala playing like this it's
definitely going to run down very very
slow forcing people into a scramble
situation oh but gets the trade here
yeah all the reasons
oh boy oh looking for something nice
obvious oh no he hit him with that low
one too many times black zombie snuffed
it out and here we go now black summer
once again on set point can he take it
are we gonna get another final fan
around sam dude we're this tournament is
the hype this
is i rename it the tekken hype challenge
man this is
let's go big tobaccy all right send it
forward dash in tooth fairy give them
knees on
okay
pushing
keeping distance
you needed that right there colic is
going to be on his last legs here
looking for the unblockable news enough
to take it colic
he's got really available
rage drive is available for what's black
as i'm going to do he's back dashing
he's got the life lead uh oh big damage
oh
that hits it we are going to another
final final round ladies and gentlemen
60 seconds one of these boys is going
home oh no nice chicken all right
he's waking up now yep
look at this he's got the lead here he
knows he doesn't need to go in he
doesn't need any risks whatsoever
but wait a minute black cause i'm
looking to poke him down to her to a
similar lively okay
these both you guys are panicking right
now we've got another situation just
like the last set
both guys panicking playing very very
patient but kind of has the live feed
right now black summer can you get a
counter hit can he get something looking
for it he's looking for it a lot big
magic forward there just sending it up
a nice
okay
hello
adjustment
give some rage oh that's gonna be yes
the reversal
that was insane what a player what a
player and he's moving on we're gonna
see him again
let's go man shout out to the black
azama what a display of tekken man that
was a roller coaster that was an
emotional